c'est le bout du chemin pour lino
zambito
cet après midi un juge doit prononcer sa
peine au palais de justice de saint
jérôme
mais à cette heure si ce n'est pas son
propre sort qui le préoccupe le plus
difficile c'est mes enfants de savoir
qui vivent un stress sont à l'école qui
ont les kings subd pour savoir qu'est ce
qui marque ce qui rend ces enfants
nerveux c'est la possibilité bien réelle
que le juge l'envoie en prison dès ce
soir j'ai des craintes d'un sens que
quand je frappe des fanges frappé juste
alliez jouer bach l'heure un peu d'un
crime organisé
ils ont eu beaucoup de 70 des enfants
d'école qui sont là fait que oui je dis
règne pour ma sécurité
c'est aujourd'hui le grand jour un taux
de marge ce soir ken pereira a le coeur
à fait classique un chanceux je vois pas
ça tout le monde en parle pour mon livre
j'ai ça fait deux ans qu'on triche un
peu ma vie mes derniers navin au
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un sportif du
portugal il fait les choses en grand
des pâtisseries pour toute l'équipe de
tout le monde en parle
merci beaucoup monsieur la presse
évoquant brigade
j'ai quand même commis des gestes sont
défendus sont sanctionnés par la loi un
pillage droit fin face à sorrus et lino
zambito a plaidé coupable aux
accusations qui pesait contre lui dans
le doubs si boisbriand notamment
corruption et fraude
il espère que sa collaboration à la
commission charbonneau rendra le juge
plus clément que ça soit terminé pic on
tourne la page une fois pour tous au
vert
stamos et la lino zambito et ken pereira
ont été des acteurs principaux de la
commission charbonneau qui a fait partie
du paysage québécois pendant quatre ans
ce soir on vous emmène dans les
coulisses de la commission rencontrer
des gens dont la vie a été changée par
cette expérience une personne à sa ces
moments-là bizarre
j'ai réussi mon défi de ne pas passer
dans les formes non cash
et c'est le petit dit que j'ai fait la
loi dans ma tête ça en fait
pendant plusieurs années avant la
commission charbonneau presque personne
ne s'inquiétait de la déviance qui
s'installait dans l'industrie de la
construction vient de tout un jet set
qui avait eu milieu l'aube afin puis ça
allait bien l'industrie li collisionneur
collisionner lee corrupteurs corrompait
le gouvernement investissait les dollars
pleuvait dizaine d'entrepreneurs dans un
restaurant huppé soit montréal ou à
laval salle et inhibe la pensée de 7 8
ans la noix puis à parly parfumé 6 ans
puis
tout était beau à l'époque la vie était
plus dur pour ken pereira un
syndicaliste alors inconnu du public
juste avant que je passe au 5ème puis la
commission charbonneau le monde oublie
que c'est ont menacé on a mis alors
devant ma porte
enveloppé dans un journal un rat symbole
de traîtrise c'est ainsi qu'il est perçu
au sein de la ftq construction son
propre syndicat
mais bon ma nation digne on écrit un
texto dans 3o bon il n'a jamais su de
qui provenaient ces menaces mais il sait
qu'on veut le faire taire sans relâche
ils dénoncent la discrimination
syndicale et les fraudes du patron de la
ftq construction
dans ce même moment le la police se
rendaient à bien cogner à ma porte
avions dit que ma vie est en danger
c'est un film ne fait appel à trois
heures d'appels humidité de chez oh
ouais pas ton sera donné cet ordre royal
versa il sensé vie en danger
désespéré il se tourne vers radio canada
il devient le premier à lancer l' alerte
donc ça joue pas mal dur ajouté aux
rares dans la construction
ben c'est plate à dire je pensais qu'on
avait évolué depuis les années soixante
dix la commission klich dédé desjardins
pays ça peut changer pour lino zambito
l'émission enquête a plutôt bouleverser
sa vie
le pour y tourner en vraie menace la 15
octobre 2009 le reportage enquête selon
nos évaluations infrabec a obtenu 50
millions de dollars en contrats à
boisbriand seulement au cours des cinq
dernières années
c'est plus de la moitié de tous les
contrats de la ville pour s'être cachée
celle aucun moment d'année l'emphase et
et michaux - son entreprise fait
faillite
il est sous enquête puis la police la
red
il devient le symbole de ceux qui
méprisent désormais les québécois un
entrepreneur art d'un croquis sur la fin
cet arrêt she has que les foules mais la
corruption s'étend bien au delà de
boisbriand à partir de l'automne 2009
je vais visiter le demande d' enquête
publique concernant le secteur de
l'industrie de la construction
c'est humiliant pour le québec ça
détruit la confiance du public dans
notre démocratie soit il déclenche une
commission denquête soit il démissionne
de son poste de premier ministre
nous avons impérativement corps une fois
besoin de mettre sur pied une commission
d'enquêté sur la construction
qu'est ce que le gouvernement tente plus
là pour en fait déclenché cette
commission jean charest résiste deux ans
on essaie justement aux policiers
l'occasion de faire leur travail
15 sgi de collusion de corruption de
mafia c'est vraiment une affaire de
police nous on veut que les gens soient
amenés devant des tribunaux il cède le
19 octobre 2011
notre gouvernement annonce la mise en
place d'une commission d' enquête sur
l'octroi et la gestion des contrats
publics dans l'industrie de la
construction
et c'est la juge france charbonneau qui
va diriger cette commission
tu pues t elle était leader avec ma
conjointe et le soir puis ce soit je me
réjouissais manger très belle domination
la mouche au bras gauche pourtant fait
un bon travail et mâcon je me dis c'est
ce que tu comptes à peine pour près de
pau cage non longue ça me surprendrait
énormément comme apple elle m'a dit
bonjour c'est france charbonneau
faites comme moi j'imagine que tu doutes
pourquoi je t'appelle quand je reviens
d'un message madame charbonneau
bonjour m tremblay j'aimerais bien vous
parlez est le message suivant soit pas
de local c'est denis gallant qui me
disait hey salut sinon le besoin d'un
cinquième procureur tout de suite je
sais que c'est quelque chose à quoi je
peux pas dire non mais j'ai des gens qui
passent et j'ai déjà la maison que je
couche consul sais que ce que je faisais
à france à ce moment là
et je peux tu y réfléchis baisse korek
rappelle moi dans 15 minutes 5
je me permets de vous présenter les
avocats plaideurs de la commission le 22
mai 2012 france charbonneau inaugure les
audiences publiques m sylvain lussier
est ce que c'est très excitant sont des
mandats avec un beaucoup de visibilité
du travail extrêmement intéressant m
sonia lebel non je profite d'être
construction je faisais je n'ai pas de
planter un clou à peu près l'état d'une
méconnaissance m denis gueule et on me
donnait cette opportunité l'eau la seule
chose par contre c'est que leur leur
faux projet de l'inca m simon tremblay
un couteau à double tranchant
c'est à dire qu'on peut mais royalement
tous sont bien conscients du risque
d'échouer
le mandat est si large que sonia lebel
on a parfois le vertige
regardez l'octroi des contrats dans le
milieu de la construction
pour les 15 dernières années municipales
provinciales
ajoutez-y un port de financement juste
pour être certain qu'on manque pas de
travail on revoit crime organisé des
fois on se demande ce que c'était pas
pour noyer le poisson
c'est ce qu'ils avaient des intentions
politiques en arrière le 15 ans c'était
pour s'assurer qu'il n'y avait pour que
les gouvernements libéraux qui étaient
dans la mire de la commission on nous a
demandé de vider l'océan avec une
cuillère je sais ça fonctionne paulo
pour les procureurs l'enjeu et
professionnel pour certains témoins
l'enjeu est très personnel certains se
font déjà intimidés dans leur milieu ça
des véhicules suspects requis rodelle
autour de ma résidence
stéphanie bérard était la directrice de
l'association des entrepreneurs en
maçonnerie du québec
de stationner devant la résidence et
puis laisser ses lumières ouverte le
soir par exemple juste pour intimider
pour remontrer on surveille le pied en
loges le cauchemar commence dès qu'elle
annonce son intention de témoigner
légalement un message vocal sur mon
répondeur me disant l'eau se voit fermer
ta gueule
le crime organisé cette est infiltrée
dans le secteur de la maçonnerie
je dormais plus mes enfants leur charme
et au sous sol
il y avait leur salon le salon d'ado
tout seul alors chants et tambours
je dormais dans le salon sur les divers
à côté de la chambre de mes enfants
c'est le seul moyen pour moi de pouvoir
honorer m'endormir
certains ne veulent pas que la
commission découvre la vérité stéphanie
bérard elle doit maintenant décider si
elle restera chez elle dans la peur ou
si elle ira témoigner
dans les coulisses de la commission les
enquêteurs travaillent sans relâche pour
recruter les témoins ils vont voir leur
plus improbables alliés je voyais la
preuve est que shaw qui avait contre moi
puis je commence un jeu pas sorti du
bois
maman venise édictées donnez moi
quelqu'un jours et je vais vous
le premier témoin vedette de la
commission arrive en juin 2012
le sud chez nous est entré dans la salle
j'avais l'impression qu'une rock star
n'a dans un très beau jurer sur les
saintes et ont juré de dire la vérité
toute la vérité est autre chose que la
vérité du jus et moi monsieur duchesneau
j'avais de l'admiration pour lui et
c'était le tremblay était l'avocate du
parti québécois la commission à la fin
de son témoignage
il est arrivé que son rapport bénévoles
on parle par exemple 70% de l'argent
consacré aux partis politiques aux
provinciales ne serait pas issus de dons
officiels enregistrés sur un second gros
je me disais mais sur quoi repose cette
déclaration non moi je trouvais que ça
méritait quelques questions elle
découvre l'impact de talonner en direct
un témoin que tous veulent croire vous
me demandez de commenter sa réaction c
est pas si vous nous lisez surprise
surprise et impassibilité d'assises et
les possibilités dans ce jeu on peut
jouer avec les mots ça c'est un bel
exemple
oui je vais vous poser des questions
puis soly d'accord si dans votre sens
avéré et de quelle serait la réponse
même la présidente on est empreinte ce
qu'ils les montrent qu'ils ont été
enlevés d'un brouillon une version
préliminaire qui a jamais vu jour je
veux bien tenté de répondre sans
faudrait retourner dans le temps
pouvez-vous à prendre l'engagement pour
voir si c'est possible de répondre
la crédibilité de jacques duchesneau
malmené à la commission charbonneau et
puis après ça les médias se sont
déchaînés
elle est rabroué par pauline marois est
coachée par les chroniqueurs et les
insultes pleuvent sur twitter il y avait
des messages méchants mesquin personnel
mais ça c'est pas tellement de ce mois
ce que j'ai trouvé le plus c'était de
voir des gens qui disaient qu'est ce que
le pq a à se reprocher pour avoir une
avocate ou si agressive
on aura l'occasion sur le voir ça va
être un plaisir partagé
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait poser des
questions s'il vous plaît habitué à
l'anonymat des palais de justice
la procureur chef sonia lebel et ses
collègues deviennent des vedettes du
petit écran
je suis passée de l'anonymat à la
reconnaissance publique en 24 heures
c'est presque d'un coup sec ou un moment
donné on se trouvait sur la rue - denis
gallant
on est allés dîner au centre-ville de
montréal et il y avait notre phase sur
l'écran j'ai un nom c'est assez pour
manger nos sushis mais adonis des
bricoles si nous c'est certain samedi
matin jogging en espadrilles tout était
posé des problèmes on peut reconnaître
c'est un peu intimidant
il y avait déjà et que vous ressemblez
l'avocat du parti québécois
plus moyen de passer incognito les
rencontres secrètes avec les témoins
qu'on veut recruter se complique on
prépare un témoin est en tête dans la
chambre d'hôtel et il y avait le livreur
bonne nourriture qui arrivait de
personnes se cachait derrière la porte
pour pas qu'elle sache qu'elle était
avec nous avec les enquêteurs de la
commission là pendant ce temps lino
zambito n'a toujours pas dit oui aux
enquêteurs de la commission
il réfléchit je vivais beaucoup beaucoup
de frustration
tout le monde pensait que les bandits
c'étaient les entrepreneurs de
construction
c'est ça qui sort terme à son puis moi
je me dis écouter dans la tragédie
c'est pas vrai qu'on va prendre la
glande pour tout le monde il prend sa
décision
ils décident de collaborer pleinement
qu'elle sait que je veux que mes enfants
retienne de moi quelqu'un qui va devant
une commission d enquête qui se souvient
de rien qui a des blancs de mémoire qui
veut pas collaborer
je suis pas au courant je ne sais pas
c'est quoi moi c'est pas vrai que cette
manne que ça se passe mais juste avant
qu il ne témoigne en public à la
commission des enquêteurs de la sq eu
voix son énorme potentiel et tente de le
recruter comme délateur pour les
enquêtes criminelles
on va croire identité hollande dans mes
ongles en resta là puis on change de
mêlée toujours bon c'est non c'est non
je rien sans moi il veut bien témoigner
à la commission mais pas devenir
délateur pour la police il ne veut
surtout pas changer de ville et
d'identité il somme les policiers de
trouver une autre façon d'assurer sa
sécurité
rangez vous qui m'arrivait
parce que s'il m'arrive de quoi votre
commission vient tombe à l'eau si
quelqu'un main la brutalise ou à lèvres
les gens vont croire la panda venait
témoigner c'est au même moment stéphanie
bérard l'ancienne directrice de
l'association de la maçonnerie vit
toujours dans la peur de ceux qui
veulent empêcher de témoigner
c'est là qu'ils ont instauré la
protection policière
donc des policiers passaient 18 fois
devant ma maison sur 24 heures c'est
assez pénible comme situation j'aurais
pu sombrer l'eau est tombé en dépression
profonde puis hier
pendant ce temps estelle tremblay va
québec rencontré le pq certaine qu'on
mettra fin à son mandat après la tempête
qu'elle a soulevée avec jacques
duchesneau et c'est ce qu'elle souhaite
je suis revenu bien triste moment des
attaques aussi j'avais tout essayé pour
y mettre fin
dans la vie explique jon enquiquineuse
chercher avait coûté en tout même s'il
avait du talent allait desservir
j'allais poser quand même la question si
j'avais tout expliquer ça non vion était
d'accord a insulté au printemps elle
reçoit maintenant des compliments du
public
je regardais twitter là je savane contre
interroger les gens m'écrivent est les
questions à poser
puis j'en avais des bonnes
cet équivalent témoigne que vous avez
plus de plaisir au d'intenses et
d'hôpitaux j'ai cycle avec les choses
déclaré solennellement de tirer verte et
toute la vérité sur la réalité change
avec la votre nom nous invite au bonjour
je suis un mytho un accueil à lundi on
va faire concédé mais rappelle riz comme
si sega 4h25
on la regarde maman vraie manette on est
sorti du cycle la question qui tue
arrive en étant dans ce cercle fermé
lors y avait des règles et une de ses
règles hausse était de payer une cote
aux prophéties lié avec wi lan dans ma
tête ça en fait
le g10 war on est rendus dans les choses
sérieuses deux et demi pour cent la
valeur du contrat
jeudi enfin la matière je faisais on
vient de la soie recettes connues
en coulisses les policiers qui le
percevez hier comme un bandit le
traitent maintenant comme un héros
c'était des gens avec les médecins qui
me donnaient des arrêts fallait
quelqu'un dit je te lève mon chapeau
lino et ce tout le monde lâcher le
morceau comme toi la construction sera
purifié et tout le monde s'en porterait
mieux et personne n'aurait besoin de
gardes du corps chances de la commission
avec une veine banaliser des gaves
policiens dont un policier n'a rien ça
regardait tout bon goûter
s'il roule jamais pu sonner film n'a
jamais vécu sorte on le conduit dans un
hôtel du centre-ville de montréal
s'attend les garages par les corridors
il n'y a pas personne que je sais où
j'ai été en contact avec personne
puisons le cash au collège militaire de
saint jean sur richelieu
il est coupé de sa famille mes parents
ça a pris une courbe deux jours avant d
appeler mais pareil tu es en état de
choc qui était ébranlé l'île d'un bon
alors témoigné puis mon père sa crème
c'est humain j'aime balland tête par le
créneau rien vu il vient dans le moment
tu comprends pas qu est ce que je fais
mais le temps me donner raison
ça pue varie de millions jusqu'à lino
zambito témoigne pendant dix jours
étalés sur trois semaines puis de retour
à la maison il est à nouveau bombardée
de questions
cette fois par ses trois enfants ma
deuxième commission charbonneau commence
avec mes enfants
j'avais m avec son équipe il ya un
moment donné en fait un petit mot des
couleurs mamelles ça passera pas à me
regarder les yeux d'un malaise les deux
bras ktm fut un beat au de la commission
charbonneau césaire mort et pose la main
je me mets et vins blancs de toi et tu
placé pour me dire quoique ce soit
cette chanson rappellent à quel pereira
la période de sa vie qui a précédé la
commission charbonneau gens a dit
aujourd'hui mais il y avait des soirées
bien des journées que je pense
à quelques semaines de son témoignage
il ne pense qu'à ça je me dis ben quand
la commission va arriver le joie une
polaire je me pratique a choisi tout les
scénarios possibles commerçants pour
imaginer il note qu'un but dénoncer la
discrimination syndicale et qu'on
l'écouté jusqu'au bout mais il a peur de
ce qu'on retiendra de son passage à la
commission
tu veux pas que la commission devienne
un outil pour affaiblir le mouvement
syndical
mais en même temps je dis faut exposer
puis démontrer c'est quoi la
construction sequana l'industrie
monsieur prix vous lever pour
l'assermentation le grand jour arrive
voilà salle qui est bondé
la crème et les lots qui est rouge là je
c'est aussi le grand jour pour stéphanie
bérard j'ai un policier qui est venu me
chercher à mon travail qui m'ont escorté
jusqu'à jusqu'à la commission donc je
t'ai jamais laisser seul j'avais grandi
quand on a beau hélas encore peur de
témoigner me sonia lebel la procureur
chef la rassure vos témoignages à 10 et
c'est un peu comme rentrer dans une
pièce sombre rempli droit indique encore
mais le spotlight la lumière qu'est ce
qui arrive a dit niro et disparaissent
et c'est ce qui s'est passé
effectivement dans le crime organisé et
l'on entende j'ai jamais vécu une
situation aussi angoissant goût et ça
c'est jean-luc sont utiles ivry on
aurait peut-être progresser on aura
peut-être découvert des choses mais on
n'aurait pas eu cette même vision le
meilleur je vous remercie infiniment
pour votre témoignage je vous avais fait
preuve de beaucoup de courage
c'est l'histoire de stéphanie bérard
attire la sympathie
d'autres témoins mis en cause dans des
malversations deviennent des parias
certains se sont rendus au fond du baril
des gens que j'ai vu quand j'étais par
leur famille ou en détresse des
suicidaires
c'était vraiment des situations très
sérieuse
simon tremblay a été confronté à une
image qui n'oubliera pas une personne
qui vraisemblablement et des traces de
tentatives de suicide sur son corps puis
abandonnés lorsqu'elle a fait un geste
cette personne là j'ai vu des cicatrices
sur sa tentative de passer à l'acte donc
ça c'est quand en train d'interroger ça
refroidit un peu le moment mais on sait
le faire notre travail on peut penser
que cette piété de cas qu'on lançait des
gens quelquefois en pâture à l'opinion
publique
oui du moment violent
monde détruit des réputations en
quelques minutes
et puis c'est pas nécessairement un
effet désiré par par les procureurs de
la commission ou même ça ne l'est pas
mais c'est l'effet que ça peut avoir il
ya quelque part autant je lève mon
chapeau à ceux qui ont accepté de parler
accepté de s'impliquer accepté de se
montrer sous un jour qui n'était pas
nécessairement toujours avantageux pour
eux autant je peu étonné que d'autres
ont résisté ne l'ont pas fait parce que
parce que le prix à payer était très
cher pour ces gens là le procureur chef
est moins tendre envers ceux qui se sont
montré clairement récalcitrants qu'est
ce que vous pensez que ça existe la
mafia un monsieur milioto chaussures
pomona ce qui était peut-être le plus
dix états de se préparer justement
c'était moins en sachant pertinemment
bien que j'allais me frapper la tête
contre un mur question après question je
ne peux pas vous confirmer aujourd'hui
que j'ai signé une lettre une lettre de
sollicitation mais vu le rythme à
l'exclure dans le cadre de fonctions
comme vous me l'expliquer je ne
confirmerai pas non plus que je ne
que jeunes pour la pole exclure
tellement bien dit ouah c'est ma plus
grande déception ceux qui ont passé leur
temps à se préparer à ne pas nous
répondre
garder mon année présidentielle riche
commencer l'enregistrement j'aimerais
être capable et visuel j'ai fait parce
que c'est pas la porte est juste aux
questions ça va être beaucoup plus
rapide souviennent proche d'aller au
début l'impression que vous répondez
laquelle ce qu'on vous a posé je ne
pensais aux équipes multidisciplinaires
ses chauffeuses vous voulez pas répondre
à la question oui la ligne 60
monsieur aso nous boude ou bien ils sont
mal pris parce qu'on a un deal avec
blanchet j'ai évité de sacrés et ouais
ça soit plus facile à comprendre et
montcuq rythme encourageant
t'as pas trop le sacrifice de l'année
tri de toutes personnes d'écouter son
enthousiasme on sort des goûters
d'autres sont motivés par ce qu'ils
voient et entendent
moins d'argent qui me reste je veux plus
comme tout le monde je paie mes taxes
municipales je paye ma tbh pays-bas des
véhicules puis de voir ce gaspillage
l'eau et honte et saïda imita jobs
les procureurs sont prêts à admettre
quelques erreurs sur la forme davantage
que sur le fond par exemple d'avoir
rendu publique une longue liste de
personnes qui ont fréquenté le club
privé 357,6 la ville ce 346 pts -
j'envoyais l'utilité de l'état des
vêtements hors d'événements et les
membres noms de personnes et invite me
suis aperçu peu texte était pas heureux
dans une commission d' enquête et que
show aurait pris de sûreté avec le
témoin et sonia lebel aide mais
volontiers qu'elle a un peu dérapé avec
michel arsenault
mais votre souvenir est-ce qu'on peut
revoir le début mais certains n'ont
écouté le bilan ne ramène rien on nous
cherche ça c'est mon moment bizarre
pascal faisant le ciel fac au code on
reprend tout le monde en place oubliez
ça je leur ai fait c'est sûr et certain
système a besoin
tu vois ça me suis encore parce
qu'auparavant
est ce que ça aurait pu être plus sobre
que ce oui est-ce que je pense que des
fois c'était un peu trop un show de tv
ou traité comme un show de tv oui mais
est-ce que la valeur la plus value la
valeur ajoutée pour la société est plus
grande que peut-être les dommages ou li
blessures que sa cause est
oui je pense que oui on a eu droit à des
révélations explosives aujourd'hui
devant la commission charbonneau ouzou
vous allez payer mettant berne
l'intérieur a continué de vider son sac
ken pereira règle ses comptes avec la
ftq construction
ajoutant même que les hells angels
étaient parvenus à infiltrer la centrale
syndicale jocelyn dupuis qui était le
boss qui pue le boss
moi je pensais raynald desjardins de
bosses l'effet commission charbonneau
est remarquable dans la vie de ken
pereira qui devient célèbre
je vous connais pas ta ou pire sont
attendus sur lyon est ce que vous êtes
arrivé des choses bizarres je m'en vais
au centre d'achat à laval
charles picqué qui viennent féliciter
qui me donnent la main gilles
vaillancourt
mais super et la saison je la regarde
j'ai vu me donnèrent félicitations pour
faux témoignage bonjour je tiens à vous
féliciter pour avoir le courage de
témoigner devant la commission
charbonneau et j'ai eu des centaines et
des centaines de messages de gens la
population que je connais pas qui
m'écrivait pour me remercier d'avoir
témoigné je me suis sentie comme une
vague d'amour qu'on reçoit l'eau et pas
longtemps après le jeu recevait la
médaille du courage l'assemblée
nationale faction aussi pour moi ça a
été un petit baume apaisant sur
la douleur que j'avais vécu il est passé
de champion de la construction à
champion de la commission voici lino
zambito
la célébrité est paradoxal pour
quelqu'un qui a avoué avoir fait partie
du système de collusion lino zambito et
le premier à le reconnaître qu installer
à tout le monde un pas aucun choix entre
et puis les gens applaudissaient japon
malaise ses habitants nettement
bonsoir un moment donné j'ai réalisé mes
emails un monde clos de sport lino
zambito il y applaudit ce concours un
jeu le fait que j'ai dénoncé
c'est au client s'il vous plaît restez
assis 1 on n'est pas tout le monde en
parle maintenant qu'il est connu et
reconnu par tous lino zambito se sent en
danger le moment donné un des gens à la
garde rapprochée m'a dit monsieur un
mytho on a eu vingt que votre protection
vendredi chez vos enfants vos fans et
puis vous quelques jours on vous laisse
le quelques mois plus tard un événement
viendra lui prouver qu'il avait raison
d'avoir peur
mardi 10 novembre
c'est l'heure de vérité pour les nos 1
bit ont accompagné de sa famille il sera
dans quelques minutes si il ira au
pénitencier ou s'il pourra purger sa
peine dans la collectivité
est-ce que sa participation à la
commission charbonneau rendra le juge
plus clément
chose certaine son témoignage la mise en
danger
c'est arrivé quelques mois après son
passage à la commission
un homme se dirige vers sa table cette
personne là elle est clairement
identifiée à la mafia oui c'est quoi les
mots que cette personne nous tue mais
est juste que je te met une balle dans
la tête
mais il reste très calme j'ai regardé ça
personnel à ta place je resterais
tranquille parce que le moindre geste
fumer il ya 440 qui bouchent la vue qui
souhaitent menotté atteint et elle est
saisie le mafieux est parti même
aujourd'hui j'ai pas par des gens
intelligents
les gens étaient les gens comprennent
que ce qui s'est passé
ma crainte c'est les gens qui veulent se
faire un nom ces gens là qui sont
dangereux pour mu
on écoute à tous c'est vrai que ça fait
partie
la partie des chansons que on a beaucoup
écouté quand on travaillait au début de
l'été sonia lebel la procureur chef
était plutôt sereine à l'idée tourner la
page sur la commission charbonneau une
décision avec des informations
les choix de la commission été remise en
question en particulier l'absence de
certains témoins dans le volet sur le
financement politique provinciale je
pense que tout le monde au québec
comprend comment ça marche et union
montréal pense qu'on rende à marcher à
laval mais le point de vue pro mesiano
l'effleuré puis on a décidé d'arrêter là
il y est sûr que pour ce qui est de la
partie provinciale
c'est décevant moi je me suis dans la
première phase de manille des ingénieurs
qui disait j'en aurai long à dire sur le
provincial il date de la victoire
j'ai été quelqu'un qui a témoigné pour
eux qu'ils le défendu plusieurs fois la
commission qui ont la critique mais sur
ce point de vue lors totalement passe à
côté on n'est pas allé au fond des
choses on entend mener les mêmes
personnes les gens réclamaient si on
peut dire l'audition de témoins comme
marc bibeau qui était le grand argentier
du parti libéral on a beaucoup parlé du
rôle de l'entrepreneur marc bibeau qui
est un proche de l'ex premier ministre
jean charest georges dès qu'un ex pdg
d'une entreprise de génie-conseil par le
lui carrément de trafic d'influencé ils
ont expliqué qu'ils s'occupaient du
financement auprès des entreprises que
bientôt elle parti libéral prendrait le
pouvoir que lui sera en position pour
influencer et l'octroi des contrats
marc bibeau pourquoi vous l'avez pas
mine en bois ne discuterait pas de toute
façon particulière ça c'est sûr et
certain
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
que y'a personne à la commission qui a
pris ses décisions lance ims en
dépression est ce que on pourrait
refaire la commission autrement et les
faire en temps oui est-ce que je pense
que c'est une erreur non ces deux sera
de savoir que le public se pose des
questions sur des réseaux d'influencé
et que toutes ces preuves et frappé d'un
interdit de publication
vous comment vous avez vécu avec toutes
les critiques affecté beaucoup plus ma
famille que pouvaient m'affecter - ça
c'est clair que pour sow je trouvais
j'ai trouvé ce stress pour moi
personnellement mais pour l'entourage
s'est alors amené à vivre aussi sur
commerce pourrait plus si j'allais dit
moitié des affaires à mes parents il y
avait une crise cardiaque sa cellule
mardi 10 nov
mon père des amis du monde traditionnel
qui encore aujourd'hui la communauté
italien de belles du monde nous regarde
comment quelqu'un qui qui qui se tourne
et c'est valence et traditions ou pis tu
parle pas des enfants sans emploi dans
son domaine
banni de la ftq construction ken pereira
trouve que lancer l' alerte lui a coûté
cher
c'est plate à dire mais je ne crois pas
que le système est fait à ce moment pour
défendre ceux qui dénoncent la bonne
affaire et s'est dénoncé mais il ya des
conséquences énormes en ingénieurs parce
que yayi est venu de nous expliquer des
choses qui avait vu dans le cadre de sa
pratique cette personne n'a apparemment
qu'aujourd'hui
incapable de se trouver un emploi je
peux dire qu'elle est les venelles m
qu'elle ait servi de prête noms donc on
peut pas l'engager je trouve ça un peu
décevant ça donne quoi d'aller dénoncer
si les dommages sont encore plus sévères
nous vous remercions une fois de plus
très sincèrement pour l'intérêt que vous
avez toujours porté aux travaux de la
commission
merci alors à quoi aura servi la
commission charbonneau
je pense que c'est d'avoir confirmé ce
que vous vous aviez trouvé et de l'avoir
mis au grand jour de façon établi quel
bel exercice de démocratie parce qu'à un
moment donné que tout et n'importe qui
dans la société
un moment donné si c'est quelque chose
on pourrait obliger et tu devras répond
il tout à le faire publiquement jute way
dans dans france charbonneau père renaud
lachance
ils vont nous exposer 50-60
recommandations moi je propose qu'on
voit les appliquer tu arrivé souvent que
des comme son enquête
un des rapports tabletté
mais pour sonia lebel l'équipe qu'elle a
dirigé aura fait son travail
je suis fier d'avoir fait partie cette
équipe là je suis fier du travail qu'on
a fait puis je suis fier d'avoir
travaillé avec ces gens là
le juge a parlé
lino zambito écope de deux ans moins un
jour à purger dans la collectivité comme
il l'espérait il a évité la prison
collaborer avec la commission aurait été
un bon choix pour lui le juge a fait
ressortir que ça n'a pas été ma
collaboration à la commission
charbonneau j'aurais pu stopper sa
famille comprend maintenant mieux les
avantages d'avoir tout déballer je
m'attends à ce qu'il ya eu quelques
sourires sont des visages ce soit on
rentre à la maison
la construction s'est terminée pour lui
mais il reste amer il sent qu'il est
l'un des seuls à payer le prix de cette
période de collusion et de corruption
pour le moment qu'on dise que la police
est indépendant que le directeur des
poursuites criminelles et indépendant
moi je peux vous dire beaucoup de
pression politique
puis le jour que je vais avoir des gros
noms qui ont mouillé dans tous ces
domaines là de collusion et de
financement arrêtée
je dois y croire que ces instances
laufon leur ouvrage correctement adachi
très sceptique
presque sept ans après son premier
passage à radio canada ken pereira
revient devant les caméras
je pense que j'ai déjà aujourd'hui un
livre tu penses à tout le monde en parle
mais en rien le matin et toucher toutes
les souffrances que mes gonds payés sont
obligés de s'exiler en alberta a réussi
ailleurs les québécois sont pas capables
de bris auxquelles savoir que tout
bonjour jamais gagné jamais jamais je
gagne j'ai fait qu'est-ce que je pouvais
plus je continue à maintenir d'obopay je
pense pas que jabulani bons mecs dans
tout le monde en parle tellement c'est
beaucoup